bueno cuando estaba por terminar mi
carrera de ingeniero industrial se me
presentó una situación que tenía
resolver
tenía definir mi proyecto de tesis
y estaba un poco perdido lo bueno fue
que se me cruzó una persona y me dijo lo
que te conviene hacer es tratar de
pensar fuera de la caja
ok genial entonces alguna propuesta que
tenía que ver con las temáticas de la
creatividad el emprendedorismo y la
innovación que siempre me habían
interesado presente la propuesta y en
dos días solamente me la devolvieron
rechazadas
el argumento que me daba en ese entonces
es que no eran temas pertinentes a la
carrera de ingeniería industrial
suena loco no fue hace tanto tiempo fase
solamente 15 años
esta fue una especie de bautismo que
tuve con este asunto de pensar fuera de
la caja
lo cierto es que a la gente cuando le
venís a cambiar un poquito los esquemas
no le divierte demasiado lo cierto es
que muchas veces pensar fuera de la caja
duele
soy un tipo bastante perseverante o
cabeza dura no lo sé lo estoy trabajando
con mi terapeuta a todas las semanas y
logré convencer a mis ósea docentes a
los docentes que están en ese momento en
el departamento de la carrera que esos
temas serán interesantes y de esa manera
logré sumergirme en ese mundo de la
creatividad la innovación y el
emprendedorismo y alegrar que siempre
los súbitos juntos porque las ideas la
creatividad no se convierten en valor e
innovación por arte de magia o por
acción de la gravedad sino que necesitan
vehículos y esos vehículos son los
emprendedores
hablo de emprendedores dios en términos
generales no asociados por él con lo que
comúnmente se conoce asociados a los
negocios solamente sino como emprendedor
como las personas que se cargan una idea
al hombre y se lanzan una aventura que
es concretarla
realmente me recibí empecé a trabajar en
esos temas asesorar investigar formar a
otros y sé de lo que hoy tengo claro y
que puedo confirmar es que para innovar
con pensar fuera de la caja solamente no
alcanza además hay que ser capaces de
romper la caja
no sólo los seres humanos tenemos un
montón de habilidades algunas más útiles
otras no tanto de un montón de amigos
que por ejemplo tienen de habilidad
tocarse la punta de la lengua con la
punta de la nariz con la lengua el
cálculo que acá alguno creo que algunos
ya está intentando bueno esas son de las
que nos sirven demasiado pero después
hay otras que sí entre las cuales está
la habilidad creativa la habilidad
creativa quiere decir que podemos hacer
sinapsis es decir conexiones entre
experiencias o entre conocimientos
adquiridos para esa manera dar como
resultado nuevas ideas originales
por suerte para quienes no se sienten
demasiado duchos en esta habilidad hay
un montón de técnicas de herramientas
que se pueden utilizar así como nosotros
podemos por ejemplo ir al gimnasio para
entrenarnos o para desarrollar
determinado músculo de nuestro cuerpo
bueno también podemos utilizar algunas
técnicas herramientas algunas
actividades para entrenar a nuestro
cerebro que de esa manera sea mucho más
capaz de crear general las técnicas las
herramientas que se utilizan en
creatividad son bastante simpáticas
bastante divertidas vamos a jugar un
poquito con eso para que me gusta mucho
a mí es la de crear por ejemplo
escenarios hipotéticos y pensar en todas
las cosas de nuestro alrededor que se
modificarían si ese escenario fuese real
por ejemplo pensemos todas las cosas que
cambiarían de nuestro entorno si todos
los océanos tuviesen solamente un metro
de profundidad
bueno cambiarían seguramente el formato
de los barcos cambiarían los métodos de
pesca
bueno ni hablar los quilombos que
tendremos con el sindicato de
guardavidas que bajaría muchísimo el
trabajo y muchas veces de este tipo de
técnicas que son de crear un escenario
que es irreal que es ficticio puede
disparar ideas que son totalmente
factibles de aplicarse en el mundo real
en el que vivimos nosotros hay otra
actividad que a mí me divierte que es la
de tratar de empujar a nuestro cerebro a
lugares que habitualmente no va el tipo
está tan cómodo acá adentro tan
calientito que es muy fácil ponerle
trampitas y hacerlo a enredar y
tropezarse por ejemplo si pensamos en
asignarle un determinado aroma a un
sonido por ejemplo qué olor tendría el
canto de un pájaro o pensemos por
ejemplo en darle un determinado sabor a
un color qué gusto para cada uno de
nosotros tiene el color rojo
hay herramientas y hay técnicas que
tienen que ver por ejemplo con forzar la
unión entre dos productos que no tienen
absolutamente nada que ver entre sí y
evaluar qué producto saldría de esa
unión por ejemplo que sale de juntar un
vaso y una guitarra criolla o que sale
si tenemos que juntar o si pretendemos
juntar una birome y
es un martillo bueno de esta técnica
también han surgido un montón de
productos que nosotros utilizamos o
tomamos en nuestro día a día en nuestro
cotidiano por ejemplo si pensamos en
unir una raqueta y una picana que sale
el matamoscas alegre se lo conoce claro
exactamente lo conoce en el ámbito de
inicio lo que nos gustan las moscas es
un rendimiento y después por ejemplo si
pensamos en unir un aplauso y una
ballesta que puede salir de ahí
bueno puede salir otro matamos que has
dicho este lo traje para mostrárselos
amigos
este tipo de cosas
pero hay una herramienta ventral y es
una actividad que por lejos es la más
efectiva para estimular nuestra
creatividad que yo siempre trato de
recomendar que es el acto de viajar
viajar como sea a donde sea con quien
sea el hecho está en salir de nuestro
entorno cotidiano
y obligarnos a incomodar nos un poco
porque en esa incomodidad donde nos
encontremos con otros contextos con
otras personas con otros con otras
costumbres no solamente nos van a
disparar ideas las cosas que nos topemos
sino que además nuestro cerebro durante
los viajes se vuelve mucho más permeable
a las nuevas ideas no son pocos los
casos de personas que a lo largo de un
viaje o durante un viaje han logrado dar
con esa idea que hace tiempo buscaban y
no encontraban a mí en lo personal
viajando se me han ocurrido desde ideas
de negocios hasta juegos para hacer con
mi hija desde dinámicas para hacer con
mis alumnos en clase hasta nombres para
perros o sea de todo de todo
la
el tema de la creatividad porque es
digamos tan importante porque la
creatividad es la materia prima de la
innovación la creatividad te permite
abrir su abanico de alternativas
ante un proceso de toma de decisiones la
creatividad te permite percibir valor en
donde otros solamente ven basura y la
creatividad no es importante es
fundamental para poder convivir con la
falta quienes emprendemos proyectos todo
el tiempo estamos conviviendo con la
falta nunca estamos frente al escenario
ideal que nos encantaría tener siempre
falta algo o plata o tiempo o
conocimiento sin embargo los resultados
se logran porque con creatividad con
ingenio a mi personalmente me gusta
vamos a llamarlo rebusque logramos que
gran parte de esos problemas se puedan
resolver y los obstáculos se puedan
esquivar
aún así es importante aclarar que aún no
existe una técnica o por lo menos hasta
hace cinco minutos en que empezara esta
charla no no existe una técnica que
garantice el hallazgo de la gran idea
eso es un tema meramente estadístico y
azaroso es muy simple cuantas más ideas
generemos más posibilidades de dar con
una buena vamos a tener lo desconfío
bastante de los que dicen ser genios
creativos si confío en que hay muchas
personas con mucha capacidad de generar
muchas ideas y que cada tanto la pegan
con alguna genialidad el proceso
creativo es muy ineficiente genera mucho
más residuo inútil que valor real
la la mayoría de las ideas que se
generan son descartables por eso entrar
en un proceso creativo sin estar
dispuesto a fallar es sacar un pasaje
directo a la frustración
la creatividad es hermosa pero hay que
saber que también es muy caprichosa y
hay que saber gestionarla y tenerle
paciencia
el proceso creativo es estático la
aparición de la gran idea en nuestra
cabeza genera una sensación de mucho
placer y entusiasmo
pero las ideas por sí solas carecen de
valor son como semillas en la palma una
mano que pueden ser muy sanas de alta
calidad exóticas pero si no contamos
además con un terreno fértil bien
soleado con la dosis correcta de agua
esas semillas no van a terminar dándonos
ningún fruto
por eso concentrarse en desarrollar la
capacidad creativa individual cuando lo
que queremos es innovar hay que saber
que no es suficiente dicho de otra
manera los pensadores fuera de las
cajistas en soledad no van a lograr
llegar demasiado lejos porque para que
sus ideas prosperen
y sean sostenibles inevitablemente
necesitan de la existencia de otros
otros que muchas veces están seguros
resguardados cómodos y la caja los
protege la caja funciona como barrera
las paredes de la caja están conformadas
por creencias hábitos rutinas mandatos
miedos
y a pesar de ser todos estos factores
intangibles suelen ofrecer mucha más
resistencia de los objetos materiales
entonces qué hacemos
seguramente muchos de ustedes están
esperando el momento en que yo rompa
esta caja
ello sería lo esperable lo previsible
por lo tanto voy a hacer todo lo
contrario
cuando me refiero a romper la caja no me
refiero a ejercer un acto violento
y pasarla a pedazos sería probablemente
el primer impulso pero no el
verdaderamente efectivo según mi
experiencia para romper la caja lo que
hay que hacer es todo lo contrario hay
que lograr de alguna manera a mirarse
con la caja y ayudarla a que se rompa
solita y eso es un verdadero arte
quienes pretendemos ser seres
transformadores en esta era del talento
sabemos que ya no es suficiente con
saber ni con saber hacer además es
fundamental saber ser y convivir no hace
muchos años que trabajo en promover la
cultura de la innovación en ambientes
rígidos y hasta conservadores ayudó a
que las ideas de los individuos que
están dentro de organizaciones en
comunidades sean escuchados y que sus
ideas prosperen
ayudó a modificar estructuras y aceitar
sistemas para que las ciudades nazcan y
fluyan con mayor facilidad colaboro con
las personas ahí adentro para que
entiendan que la caja es vulnerable es
débil ante la empatía la persuasión y
los buenos resultados
cuando quienes están contenidos por la
caja empiezan a ver que fuera de ella la
cosa empieza a funcionar de a poquito se
empiezan a sumar y ahí la caja empieza a
dejar de existir para que suceda eso es
un proceso que puede resumirse en tres
siglas a pepe acciones perseverancia y
paciencia
lo cierto es que todos estamos
contenidos dentro de alguna caja todos
formamos parte del contenido de alguna
caja pero a su vez todos somos capaces
de pensar fuera de ella entonces la
pregunta que surge es qué pasaría si
logramos crear sistemas que ayuden a
sumar las capacidades creativas
individuales
la respuesta a eso es muy simple
nos convertimos en un entramado
tremendamente poderoso consolidamos una
red capaz de proveer muchas ideas muchas
de las cuales tienen alto potencial de
convertirse en importantes innovaciones
si bien empieza a haber algunos casos
sobre este tema del aprovechamiento de
la inteligencia colectiva aún las
instituciones las organizaciones tanto
públicas como privadas no han logrado
desarrollarlo ni expandirlo lo
suficiente
pensemos por ejemplo en esta situación
imaginemos una plaza una ciudad un
domingo día soleado hay muchas personas
interactuando
juegan y charlan toman mate en esa plaza
está jorge es un cuarentón y tiene dos
hijos y mientras observa a sus hijos
subirse al tobogán de la plaza se da
cuenta que se agregara solamente un
escalón en el último tramo de la
escalera haría a ese juego mucho más
seguro y accesible algo muy simple pero
muy valioso también
a jorge le ocurrió algo que a nosotros
nos puede suceder habitualmente de hecho
nos ocurre ante una situación y un
entorno cotidiano se nos ocurre una idea
espontánea pero qué hace jorge con ella
a donde la presenta a quien como hace
para que yo que integró esa misma
comunidad mente y no de que se dice ya
existe y de que pudo ayudarlo a él a
realizarla
lo cierto es que todos sabemos que algo
tan simple en realidad implica
involucrarse en un proceso que es
tedioso y que no nos garantiza
absolutamente ningún resultado jorge
también sabe esto entonces qué hace
descarta leer
hay estudios que indican que la mayoría
de las ideas no fracasan porque fallan
en la implementación sino que fracasan
simplemente porque nunca se inician
lo que le pasó a jorge a nosotros nos
pasa todo el tiempo que nos han ocurrido
muchas veces ideas para mejorar la
comodidad de nuestro auto o para mejorar
la circulación o la señalización en el
supermercado al que vamos habitualmente
o se nos han ocurrido ideas para mejorar
el servicio del banco del cual somos
clientes ideas que muchos de nosotros
estaríamos dispuestos a compartir porque
en definitiva van a mejorar productos
que nosotros consumimos y con los cuales
interactuamos
aun las organizaciones esto no lo están
aprovechando miles de personas son miles
de oficinas de ideas espontáneas y lo
paradójico es que cuando nos ocurren las
ideas no tenemos ni idea de qué hacer
con ellas lo paradójico es que cuando
pensamos fuera de la caja
automáticamente nos topamos con ella
yo sueño con habitar en contextos más
abiertos a escuchar las ideas de quienes
conviven
tienen ganas e intenciones de proponer
mejoras para los entornos comunes
y las personas yo sueño con que haya más
canales físicos y digitales donde
presentar esas ideas que se nos disparan
en los entornos cotidianos yo sueño con
que esas ideas sean recibidas por
personas capaces con el rol asignado de
no solamente leerlas y archivar las sino
y evaluarlas e impulsarlas yo sueño con
más presupuestos asignados a la
consolidación de áreas de innovación
abierta e inteligencia colaborativa yo
sueño con que ideas como la de jorge en
algún momento transiten por caminos
mucho más ágiles y llanos y que sus
hijos puedan ver las realizadas y
disfrutarlas
yo sueño con que las empresas nos
escuchen mucho más a los clientes que
tenemos ganas de mejorar los productos
que ellos fabrican yo sueño con que al
lado de cada libro de quejas haya un
libro de ideas y soluciones en los que
también podamos expresarnos yo sueño con
mas hackathon es idea tones y todos los
demás tones que congregan a muchos
individuos a pensar colaborativamente ya
desarrollar soluciones yo sueño con más
ciclos usted que divulgan ideas que vale
la pena compartir yo sueño con que las
organizaciones en algún momento valoren
mucho más la creatividad y el espíritu
emprendedor de sus colaboradores estoy
convencido que cuando logremos
consolidar sistemas que faciliten la
vinculación entre individuos que piensan
de manera creativa de forma sincrónica y
atomizada vamos a lograr vivir en
contextos menos
y ahí va a cobrar real sentido el pensar
fuera de la caja
y desarrollar la habilidad creativa de
las personas es una tarea hermosa pero
insisto el verdadero desafío está en
lograr que las ideas que se generan se
concreten y en eso pasó buena parte de
mi día a día como profesional por eso a
través de esta charla quiero
comunicarles a todos los demás
entusiastas que así como yo gozan de
idear y trabajar para la consolidación
de estos sistemas de aprovechamiento de
la inteligencia colectiva que quedan
formalmente invitados a acompañarme para
que así todos juntos en algún momento
logremos
romper la caja muchas gracias